[Music]
[Applause]
these Ross Tucker's CBS Westwood one
color analyst host of Ross Tucker
football podcast the former NFL
offensive lineman host of even money a
betting podcast our good buddy joining
us as he always does every Monday the
best team in football right now is who
Ross Tucker
oh I think it's the Philadelphia Eagles
Dan and I think it's hard to make an
argument otherwise at this point that
was an epic Beatdown of a Tennessee
Titans team that never loses two games
in a row that I have tremendous amount
of respect for my former teammate Mike
Vrabel as the head coach you know the
Titans are tough you know they're going
to be in every game they weren't at all
I mean the Eagles totally dominated them
up front both sides of the ball Dan if
they want to run for 350 yards they do
that against the Packers you want them
to throw for 350 yards they do that
against the Titans now they have six D
tackles a bunch of d-linemen getting
after Tannehill even their special teams
were better I think Jalen hurts is
probably at this point the MVP of the
league which is wild to even say I think
that right now it's the Philadelphia
Eagles I think they have by far the
strongest argument okay then second best
team is who
well that's a little bit more difficult
I do not think it's the Minnesota
Vikings you know the Vikings have won
every close game I mean the law of
averages Dan you've been doing this a
long time you never win every close game
they've won every close game they're
only two losses they got blasted by the
Eagles and Cowboys okay the Vikings are
the first team in league history to
start a season 9-0 in games decided by
eight points or less so that backs up
your claim here I mean I'm going to use
that all week by the way thank you for
that stat of the day
that was awesome I'm gonna use it all
week and what's really wild to me about
that damn it's not like they have
Mahomes as their quarterback right like
it's not like they have Joe Montana and
you're like okay well they're gonna win
their fair share of close games they're
gonna win six out of nine or seven out
of nine it's cousins and it's it's it's
a wild stat right now
um I still think the Chiefs are up there
the Bangles I like the Niners as well
although that's a little bit of a
different conversation now with the
Jimmy G injury and certainly the bills
are still in the mix I think it's clear
the Eagles are the best I think those
three or four teams I just named Buffalo
Cincinnati Kansas City maybe the Cowboys
maybe the Niners are in the mix to be
the next best one wait maybe the Cowboys
what am I missing here third in offense
third in defense
is it is this just an anti-cowboy bias
by you
no I don't think so I I think the
Cowboys absolutely deserve to be in the
mix I think they are one of the three
four best teams in the NFL absolutely
there should there should now I will
also say this it was 21-19 at home in
the fourth quarter against the Colts it
wasn't an overwhelmingly impressive
performance until all the turnovers
happened late in that game
um but they're playing at a really high
level as well I think
I think I'll take the Cowboys probably
right now over the Niners with party at
quarterback and the Vikings so the two
best teams in the NFC might both be in
the NFC east and it might be the two
teams that destroyed the Minnesota
Vikings earlier in the year what can the
Niners do with Jimmy Garoppolo done for
the year
not much
um they're not like there's anybody out
there I guess they could maybe call like
a Philip Rivers
no no we can't do that
why not no no I I'd rather call Drew
Brees uh as long as he didn't die from
being uh you know electrocuted or
whatever happened struck by lightning
um
God you can now you can't bring in
Philip Rivers
I I hear you I wonder who they would
consider I think they need to consider
somebody I'm sure Farr would love to
change the conversation around him right
now farv wouldn't mind being in the
headline no no no we can't have far back
no I mean we we we can't we we can't do
that
um all right a couple other things here
quarterback 25 or under that you would
start your franchise with so I give you
Lamar Kyler Joe burrow or uh Justin
Herbert or other
Tua
well Hertz is in there
oh yeah I think you got to put Hertz in
there right now definitely not Kyler
Murray or Lamar Jackson uh how old's
Josh Allen he's older than 25 26. okay
out of those guys it's either Joe burrow
or Hertz for me
um youth you would take hurts over
Justin Herbert
yes I would
yeah I think Herbert is fantastic and I
will say this
it's a little hard to evaluate those
guys at times I'm watching both those
games yesterday Jalen hurtstand at times
has like five or six seconds to throw
the ball and there's nobody around him I
mean the clean meanwhile you watch
Herbert
I mean Chandler Jones Max Crosby they
were all over I mean he's running around
he's trying to throw the ball like this
I will say the thing that makes me lean
towards hurts it is just so valuable
having a quarterback that can run like
that I mean it just opens up so many
things for your offense the question is
like
what does that mean five years from now
or ten years from now when they're
running isn't as much of a threat but
Jalen hurts has real Dan I I thought
maybe this year could be a top 15
quarterback maybe I'm stunned by this
Herbert was hit 14 times yesterday
yeah the Chargers are the same thing
every year I know it's got to be
maddening to be a fan of their I buy in
guilty as charged it feels I know it's
every year when I go no this is the year
nope this is no
uh but Joe burrow I think is the right
answer there
yeah now he has a decent injury history
although I will say this about Joe
running a little bit more than I ever
thought he had in him he's not a runner
right they're not he's scrambling yeah
he scrambles yeah he can get a couple
you need a quarterback it's really hard
now if your quarterback can't get a
couple first downs with their legs they
even have called a couple quarterback
draws now for Joe yeah he missed a
handoff yesterday and followed the
running back up for positive yardage I
think burrow is a very very good answer
I think
the the leaning towards burrow would be
he's already shown he can do it in the
playoffs yeah at a high level and win
those games in the playoffs Hertz has
not shown that Hertz has one playoff
game against the Bucks and he was awful
yeah I think that's where the Tipping
Point is for Joe burrow because he went
to the Super Bowl and you saw him go Toe
to Toe with Mahomes and didn't he he
didn't blink in a couple of those passes
were really difficult passes with the
game on the line you know what I think's
interesting about that Dan and and
rightfully so
no matter what his stats are this year
no matter how well he's playing there
are a bunch of people that still won't
totally Buy in the hurts until they see
him do it in one of those back and forth
games against Mahomes or Josh Allen or
maybe bro and I get it I I totally get
until they see him do it in a big game
playoffs or whatever against a
quarterback like that people are still
going to be skeptical of hurts I think
that's fair until he shows it yeah
because he did not look comfortable in
the game against Tampa Bay last year by
the way where is Tampa on the the
landscape of good teams
great teams in the NFC
not in the top four they're they're not
I think they are a clear step below
Vikings Cowboys Niners Eagles and
they're gonna be probably eight and nine
in host a playoff game
yeah and the thing that's crazy is they
still have enough good players and
because of Brady none of us would be
like shocked if they went and won a
couple playoff games I don't see them
winning three though man they would
really have to turn this thing around to
be I mean in in consecutive weeks to
beat like the Cowboys the Vikings the
Niners the Eagles you know some
combination of two or three of those I
just don't see it Ross will be on the
call Saturday for Army Navy for Westwood
One
uh
what's the weather supposed to be like
in Philadelphia
you know I didn't even look yet I was
just about to pull it up I'll say this
my single favorite day of the year Dan
every year
um Saturday it'll be it'll be nice
partly sunny high of 44. so it doesn't
look like we're getting a weather game I
try to describe it to people you know I
grew up outside of Philadelphia I never
went people would say oh you got to go
to the Army Navy and you got to go I
know I was like I got Penn State season
tickets like I never went
you gotta go anybody watching or
listening you have to go it's hard to
explain
how your heart feels during that day but
it just feels awesome everybody in there
is like bursting with pride and
patriotism no matter what the record is
no matter what's going on I think it's
the greatest rivalry in sports I know
people say Ohio State Michigan those
guys are all already have agents they're
going to sign with that they know
already they're all looking NFL for
these guys this is it this is it like
there is no bigger game they're not
going to the playoff college football
playoff they're not going to the NFL
they're representing millions of men and
women that watch the game to me there is
no bigger game
we'll be uh we'll be watching we'll be
listening thank you Ross absolutely see
you Dan that's Ross Tucker CBS Westwood
one color analyst host of Ross Tucker
football podcast available every Monday
always great to talk to him and he's
right about this the atmosphere it's not
about the records of the teams it's the
atmosphere that you have that you can't
replicate and if you do get that
opportunity I've said before if you
could ever get to West Point and watch a
football game in October early November
it's gorgeous and you will never feel
prouder ever